[Music]  selling humans is drugs you're the only  one that can stop them we realize we're  gonna have to take out the entire alien  drug cartel  you're just going to leave me here in in  what space everybody lives in space  including you  all right you're a bounty hunter now  you've got to help me rescue my friends  they're gatlians just like me  hey why are you squeezing me so tight  how about a little dinner first and some  bubble bath maybe first look at us  blasting away  oh yeah that's one of my children they  die back don't worry it's easy to make  [Music]  yes more more i need more stabbing  [Music]  everyone bite each other  [Laughter]  [Music]  oh oh oh well okay well now  well now i sorta now i can  [Music]  play it day one with game pass